ist das geil und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video okay leute wie ihr
wahrscheinlich willst braucht man als
youtube eine richtig dicke haut man muss
etwas aushalten als ich angefangen habe
mit youtube gab für mich einige momente
wo mich kommentare persönlich getroffen
haben und gedachte war das war echt
gemein von der gerade eben wenn man ein
bisschen weiter macht mit youtube wird
man irgendwann immun gegen diese
beleidigung im internet aber es gibt sie
trotzdem sie sind trotzdem darf man kann
nichts dagegen machen wenn 100 leute
euer video sehen wird garantiert einer
dabei sein der euch für eine richtige
plage loch helfen euch darauf wagt jetzt
gibt es auf youtube eine funktion
gewisse wörter zu blockieren in den
kommentaren zum beispiel gewisse
beleidigungen die öfter kommen das habe
ich auch gemacht und was wir heute
machen es wir schauen in meine blockten
kommentare reihen die größtenteils
deswegen geblockt werden weil ich da
aufs übelste beleidigt werde
und reagieren darauf exakt das sieht so
aus sie hat man veröffentliche
kommentare wahrscheinlich dass irgend
anders und hier ist überprüfung
aufstehen und überprüfung aufstehen sind
wie gesagt die mit wörtern die ich
geglaubt habe leute alter war machte
werde es geht los mit mister was ich
hatte früher hattest du so viel wer
jetzt nicht mehr müssen voll die
frischen socken gewesen sein nach nach
nach ironie ich gar nicht mal so übel
ich könnte stundenlang machen das super
groß schreibt bitte abonniert meinen
kanal nicht oder ihr werdet sterben
ordnete kommentare leute ich weiß ganz
genau warum ich das geblockt habe in
meinen kommentaren dieses abonniert
meinen kanal was mir letzten zeit
aufgefallen dass mit den kommentaren
leute irgendwie 90 prozent sind nur noch
leute die sagen hey der sg auch
möglichen kommentar will ja auch locken
hat bleibt diesen kommentar wenn ihr
auch stoffwechsel betreibt in pocking
homo sapiens sapiens leicht diesen
kommentar möchte von allen guten
geistern verlassen
ursprünglich waren dafür da feedback zu
geben oder irgendwie auf die inhalte im
video einzugehen mittlerweile gibt nur
noch darum dass irgendwelche leute daran
aufgeilen wollen dass sie unter einem
video 100 langsam wieder auf zwei arme
hat leipzig 1 kommentar damit die
möglichkeit bekommen darf mutter
für youtube niklas weg schreibt diese
kommentare du [ __ ] schließlich ein
anderer youtube bahnhof fig einzelstück
scheint sich eine portion beleidigung
gestellt folien welche mutter soll ich
den fitten okay also okay aber beleidigt
aber nur irgendeine muss nicht meine
rein als wenn ihr irgendeine mutter
kennen dieser kommentar sei 490 schreibt
die villa liest euch bitte es ist kein
deutscher athlet liegt euch bitte meinen
kommentar ganz durch also alles mit
meiner geburt an punkt punkt mehr
anzeigenkunden job jetzt kommen richtig
auf youtube oder das ist mehr anzeigen
job und ein gehirn implodiert leute
wieso gibt es immer noch menschen die
solche kommentare schreiben
ich bitte euch leute wären die
vielleicht solche kommentare nicht leute
die einfach schreiben hey habt ihr auch
zwei beine hat man neigte was nicht das
sind leute die die youtube kommentare
aus egoismus aus eigennutz ruinieren und
vereinfachen oder mit dem preis bekommen
der nie wieso schreibt untermain youtube
kkw action video jugendwohnen was machst
du die ganze zeit stoppt egal denn nicht
wieso ich kann mir doch nicht ein video
von einem anderen youtube anschauen oder
irgendwas zu sagen oh gott leute opfert
der nächste kommentar wer feiert sg auf
dem mega hat wenn ein kommentar von so
anfängt dann wisst ihr es wird täglich
hilft mir ist kein deutsch zu meinen den
1500 abonnenten dann bekomme jeder das
ist kein deutsch jeder ein keks und
nicht verlosen ein paar minecraft körper
hielt mir egal
hör auf dieser kommentar geht soweit er
brauche ich gar nicht mehr fragen ob du
mich hoch nehmen will weil ich schon
dreimal hochgenommen hat allein mit
diesen kommentar des vega bitte
bitte einfach auch für peter leute habe
ich ihn für kunden beschwerten youtube
kommentare gar nicht mit ihrem
eigentlichen zweck genutzt werden ich
habe mich getäuscht
es gibt wirklich noch gute kommentare
die kritische feedback und gute inhalte
meinung in den kommentaren da lassen zum
beispiel von thun arena
er schreibt hallo ich wirklich viel mühe
gegeben [ __ ] möchte von allen guten
geistern verlassen
okay leute der kommentar als auch
gefühlt wie geil alter wenn ihr noch die
young boys haben die kommentare ich
glaube es würde gut wert dass sie die
meiste richtig bock und frage nichts
kommt halt von willi lb und er hat
hitler pikachu als profilbild warum
unterschreibt man youtube kaka trainer
für die wii action
was ist das für eine aussage wer weiß
was ich lustig und lache
was ist daran wenn ihr irgendwann hat
leute können auch mal die kommentare
schreiben 11 mir bitte ich möchte
aufhören geld zu machen möchte wird
tirol lachen also werden wir sagen
können wie das geht welches wären bund
welt online schreibt ja gestimmt aber
für andere kommentare zum beispiel von
die möhre erscheint zum ersten mal auf
trockenen zu diesem kanal gekommen und
ich muss sagen deine videos mit
schädlichen sprüche und du hast eine
lockere art ich feiere dich auf tillich
und auf dankbarkeit erstmal in vielen
lange nicht super ist das video chaos
millionen schlossherr zum video update
kann nicht abrechnen du bist du neidisch
auf ihn weil er besser als du isst und
mehr abos hat die [ __ ] lohnen denn das
mittelalter daumen hoch mittelfinger du
bist du gleich viele beleidigende
kleiner spaß
fick dich auf youtube lasst das war kurz
lacken leute spaß
fick dich auf youtube übler aus und
plakaten für die zähne wissen du damit
du kriegst du so ein scheiß die idee und
wenn noch einer was sagt ist das ist das
lustig falls der welt egal
sozusagen auf dumm und hat mich immer
hoch genommen mit dem kommentar aber
andererseits sagte lustig was berichtigt
und dumme leute fick dich aus youtube
hat sich dafür eine aussage
sowas passiert er schnüffelt das ist ein
ganz klarer fall der komplette verlust
an denkleistung das gehirn setzt
komplett auf das tier wenn man für die
verschlüsselt und kann auch millionen
vor die mitglieder treten aber aber ich
gehe davon aus dass er jeden abend im
wohnzimmer spielten sich eine flasche
uhr einzukaufen und zu dem ich gut oder
mit den worten zu sagen fick dich aus
der kleber sucht okay leute das war von
diesem video aber auf jeden fall noch
mehr material das man nur die kommentare
von einer woche heißt wenn noch eine
folge haben wollte in die kommentare was
like dadurch zunächst mal wo er covert
schnell wichtiger frühstück bewahren